I love being an engineer.
It's Sherlock Holmes
and being a writer at the same time,
it's like doing stuff with your hands
and creating stuff and seeing it work.
Gil Tayar,
thank you for joining me.
How are you?
Good morning.
Good.
Very happy to be here.
I am very, very happy to be here.
We've known each other
for quite some time.
You've been a very important part
of my personal journey,
both as a mentor and judge throughout
the different hackathons
that I organized.
But more importantly,
you've introduced me
to the whole world
of developer relations and advocacy
for a great engineering and great coding.
And I've gained a lot of inspiration
seeing how much you enjoy
the work that you're doing.
And I speak to a lot of people
and I know a lot of engineers,
I don't think I've yet to meet somebody
who is as excited and enjoys their work
as much as you enjoy it.
Thank you.
So, it's really heartwarming.
Also, thank you for,
for sharing that passion.
And I'd love to focus these 20 minutes
both on that passion,
but more importantly,
on the world of engineering
and knowledge sharing.
Now, just for context,
I know that there's thought leaders
in a lot of industries, right?
There's thought leaders in philosophy,
thought leaders in economics.
But you've introduced me to the world
of those thought leaders,
also in engineering
and in good coding habits,
good engineering styles.
And that's what I'd love
to allude to later on.
But first, Gil, take me back.
Who are you and how do you become
an engineer yourself?
First of all, I'm like,
I think the first wave of developers
that wanted to be developers
in Israel and probably in the world.
I started at the age of 13,
and we're talking '84, '83.
So, I was the dawn of the PCs.
There weren't any PCs
basically before that.
It was all mainframes and minicomputers.
At the age of 13,
I got a ZX81
from the bar mitzvah.
I'm not even going to pretend
that I know what it is.
It's like this little computer
with chiclet keyboard
and it had one K of ram,
not one megabyte,
not one gigabyte,
and that one K.
And you could write
a little basic programs
and you connect it to your TV.
There weren't any monitor then.
And you stored your programs
on a tape recorder.
That's the way it was.
And I learned basic and I loved it
and I upgraded to 16k ram and everything,
and decided this is what
I want to do for the rest of my life.
I got an Apple II afterwards.
Anyway, long story short,
I ended up in Mamram,
it was the big computer unit
in the Israeli Defense Force.
It still is.
Very similar to 8200 [--].
And back then, much much more known.
I did the whole training nine months
of computer programming course
and they wanted,
and this is part of the integral journey,
in a sense it's the start of it,
and they wanted me to stay
as a trainer for computers
for the soldiers.
And I said, "Yes."
And just to understand,
I was like this shy
and not very talkative person.
But what I found out was that
once I go up on a stage, I transform.
I transform into this like,
the charismatic, talkative,
funny and everything speaker.
And, you know, when I go back down
out of the stage,
I go back to being shy.
Fascinating.
Why is that?
Obviously, slowly
when I went back out on stage,
I continued being that
talkative and funny as a person.
That's the Gil that I know.
Exactly.
So, in a way,
that was the start of changing myself
and being more confident with myself.
And talking in front of an audience
if you can do it,
it gives you that confidence
because you go and you speak
and people look at you
and they clap.
And it's an immense,
it gives you a lot of confidence.
A lot of confidence.
100%.
So, your dev relations journey
starts off back in Mamram
when you're going in your teaching
and you're training the next
cohort of engineers in the Army.
But you continue doing that
throughout your entire career, right?
And until today, you still go to
to many conferences every year.
You go on stages.
Now, you do it over Zoom obviously.
But besides that,
you still chose to be
a proper engineer.
A senior architect, right,
in various startups and companies.
So, first of all, let's focus on that.
Why be a senior architect?
What is it about being an engineer
that excites you that you said,
okay, I want to continue
being an engineer
because a lot of people that I know
at some point they said,
yeah, I had fun being an engineer,
now I want to start managing teams
and I want to to go into the more
managerial scene.
But you decided that you're
still want to be hands on
and be an active part
of the engineering part of the company,
right?
Yes.
There's this tension,
once you get good enough,
the company wants you to,
you know, go up the ladder.
And back then there was only one ladder.
You become a team leader,
and then, you know, a director
and then a VP R&D.
And that's it.
And I tried that.
And I find that
I didn't like managing people.
Back then, I didn't like
being the one responsible
for what they were writing.
And I decided,
okay, everybody wants me to be whatever
but that's not what I want.
I want to code, I'm a farmer.
I'm not you know,
I want to till the soil.
I want to smell the leaves
and figure out what's right for them.
And that is what I want.
And that is what I wanted.
And obviously, being a good engineer,
I kept being pulled up
and my career was like a seesaw,
like being pulled up
to managerial position
and then say,
"No. No, I don't want that."
After a while,
I understood that,
I'm not going to do that anymore.
And whenever people say that,
"You want to be a team leader?"
I said, "Just no."
I learned to say no.
And I love being an engineer.
It's Sherlock Holmes
and being a writer at the same time.
It's like doing stuff with your hands
and creating stuff and seeing it work
and not managing the people that do that.
And I'm not disparaging.
I mean, we need both kinds of people.
We need managers.
We need software developers.
But you can have a career
that goes the managerial way
that forced to managerial.
But today, it's called
an individual contributor, I think.
You can have a career that goes up
the more professional technical ladder
and the salaries are almost
like 10%, almost as high.
So, don't worry about your salary.
It will be high,
especially if you're a good,
I mean, a good software engineer,
a great software engineer
is worth their weight in gold.
So, if you want to do that,
please continue.
100%.
Just for that, you caught me by surprise
as I was going through my own journey
within the army in 8200.
One of the things that,
that was very interesting
for us as soldiers was that,
people that are professional
and they're staying in the army,
let's say, for five or six years,
they're still engineers,
they're still hands on,
they make more money
than somebody who is an officer
and who's leading a team of people.
And it was and, you know,
it was a big dissonance,
because especially in the army
where you're in a lot of places,
your rank identifies your credibility
and sort of your paycheck.
Here you have a unit
that is one of the leading units,
in the IDF and probably in the world
in terms of engineering, and it says,
Oh, just FYI,
if you're a professional
and you're really, really good,
you're going to make even more
than the managers.
Which is very unorthodox.
And it's very interesting.
And I'd love to hear your take,
because a lot of the people
that are watching this are not engineers.
And I'm a huge advocate
for studying computer science.
I'm now studying it hands on.
While I may not be
the most passionate guy in the room
about computer science,
I am deeply passionate
about problem solving
and the ability to problem solve
using the skills that we're gaining.
So, I'd love to hear from you.
What is so attractive to you
about engineering?
And perhaps maybe, demystify
some of the scary notions
behind what you might be doing
on a day to day basis.
There are two kinds of developers.
That's how I think about it.
The developers that think that
software development is an engineering
and the people that think that
software development is a craft.
You can immediately spot them.
The engineers think that
we can't get too perfect.
They love type systems,
you know,
because they believe
that if you get the types right,
everything will fall into place.
And then there are the craftsmen.
They understand that nothing's perfect.
And software development is like
it's like voting in the US.
You can never reach 100%
for some reason.
It's always like a tangent to perfect.
And you can strive to that,
but it's never that.
And you always have to mangle it
and fix it and deal with
technical problems.
I'm a craftsman.
And as a craftsman I love to create.
I don't see myself
as really different from a carpenter
or from someone who makes dresses
and stuff like that.
That I create using my tools,
which is like the ID
and the keyboard in the mouse.
But what I create is as creative
as other craftsman
like carpenters and whatnot.
That is how I see it.
Definitely,
there's an engineering part of it.
I'm not saying no.
But the way I see it as a craftsman,
and as a craftsman, almost an arts man,
almost an artist,
that is the passion
I bring to my work, a craft.
Right.
And I think that is a great leeway
to the notion of being
the developer relations,
and sharing your craft
and sharing your passion.
Because when you explain to me
that you're going up on stage
and you're bubbly and charismatic,
you're talking about code.
You're not talking about philosophy
or economics or politics.
You're talking about JavaScript
often code behind you
and being charismatic about it.
And that is something that I think
is going to be interesting
for a lot of people to hear,
because it's very counterintuitive.
Because up until now,
you think of an engineer,
you think of somebody who is a coder,
they're sitting down in their own silo
and they're not really human to human.
And yet you're human,
you're breaking that paradigm.
And then I encourage anybody
to go and look up Gil Tayar on YouTube
because you did many of these talks.
First of all,
what is developer relations?
And then, how does that fit
into this idea that
there are thought leaders
in the engineering world?
So, developer relations
was used to be called evangelism,
and then it became developer relations
and now its developer advocacy.
But it's basically
a lot of things in one.
One is, I'm in Applitools right now
and we do developer tools.
So, if we do developer tools,
we need to market to developers.
And who's the best person
to market to developers?
Well, other developers like myself.
So, one thing I do is
we're dealing with visual testing.
So, I talk about testing in general
and visual testing and conferences
and thus introduce people
to Applitools, not as a marketing.
I don't say a lot of Applitools.
I mean, demo with Applitools
but that's about it.
But as, okay,
there's this thing called visual testing,
let's try it out
and let's try that with Applitools.
That's one thing.
Another thing is,
is branding of the company.
I mean, WIX has used it in Israel
very nicely.
That is how we started
the developer advocacy.
They don't care about developers
in terms of developer tools,
but they want the best developers
in Israel to come to WIX.
And one of the best ways to do that
is to create a brand
of WIX engineering
so that developers will want
to come to WIX
because they hear me speak
or other developers speak at WIX.
So, that's the other side of developer
but it is great for other companies.
And the third is,
we're a community.
There's nothing about I mean,
especially opensource.
It's like everything's free,
everything's community driven.
And bringing given back
to the community
is part of what I do by educating,
by showing what I've learned
and talking and all that stuff.
So, those for me are the three
facets of developer advocacy.
And I love the three of them.
How do ideas spread
in the developer world?
So, in economics and physics would be
through scientific papers,
politics would be through views.
How do ideas spread
in the world of coding?
Because oftentimes,
the things that I see
that you're talking about,
let's say visual testing
or why should write test for your CSS,
I mean, those are things
that are not necessarily mainstream
for a lot of organizations.
And yet you're coming in,
you're suggesting a paradigm shift
or breaking conception
that is not that easy.
So, how do these new ideas
become mainstream in our world?
Just like memes,
it's a struggle between ideas out there
and the best idea wins in a way
or like the most influential people
that bring the best ideas, they win.
And in essence,
and credits a lot about you,
not just about
the ideas you bring to the table.
Credentials is going out there
and telling what you're doing.
It doesn't matter
if it's like new visual,
like visual testing
or if it's like regular stuff.
Like when I talk about ES modules
in OJS.
Go out, talk, have people see you,
do a lot of Twitter,
don't do Facebook.
Twitter is where
the thought leaders are.
Do and start small.
Don't don't try go to JS cons
right immediately,
which is like this huge conference.
Start with local meet ups.
Gain the confidence there,
gain the people there,
then start going up the ladder
to more international
Israeli conferences
and international conferences, etc, etc.
Credibility, it takes time.
Takes like six, seven years or so.
It takes time,
start small, slowly grow up.
Talk about what you know.
It doesn't really matter.
You wouldn't believe
how much people
are thirsty for information.
Talk about what you know.
It'll be great.
100%.
Now, your title is Senior Architect.
And obviously,
that's not a building architect.
It's a different type of architecture.
How is that different from being
an engineer or a coder?
What is an architect in essence?
My sarcastic answer to that is
an architect is a coder
who's too old to be called a coder.
But seriously, it's not just that.
Once you reach a certain level
of a system like of a product
where you have more code,
and it's not just one server,
one database and rest API or whatever,
once you need a system
comprised of micro services,
message passing and everything,
you need somebody to figure out
what those building blocks
of that product is.
And that's what
a software architect does, basically.
I hate software.
I call them architecture astronauts.
I hate software architects.
I just build the architecture
and then throw it to developers to code.
That is totally wrong.
I build the architecture
along with other people
and then I just plunge in
and write it as we go along.
Understanding the problems with my design
as I go along
and changing it to fit
whatever is needed.
100%.
So, for those listening
that are deeply passionate
about engineering
and they see themselves as craftsmen,
just like you see yourself
and they're excited about these,
about being that Sherlock Holmes
that you're both solving the issue,
you're also a novel writer.
I just I love that analogy.
What tips can you give
from your experience
as they're going on their journey
over the years
to become better and more skillful?
Two things at least
that come to mind.
One, understand the technology
you're working at in a deep sense.
So, if you're using premises,
please understand premises correctly.
If you're using,
I don't know, functional programming,
try to understand
what functional programming is about.
If you're using Kubernetes or docker,
how does docker work?
Theoretically,
you don't need that information.
But practically in the real world,
you do sometimes.
And the deeper your understanding is,
the more people will
come to you for advice
and you can figure out
the weird problems.
So, that's one deep understanding
of whatever you're doing.
The second thing is, overcommunicate.
I don't say communicate.
I used to say communicate.
Overcommunicate,
say more than you think
that should be said.
It's like when your acting,
when you're smiling,
you're supposed to smile
much more than regular.
So, when you're communicating,
do more than what you think you should be
and then you get
to the right level of communication.
Okay. Problem solved.
Gil, why over communicate
and not communicate?
Because people
tend to under communicate.
So, when you say to people
overcommunicate,
they give the right amount
of communication.
Also, when you're explaining something,
when you're talking
about what you're doing,
the other side
doesn't really understand the context.
So, you have to explain and re-explain
and re-explain the context.
And that context,
along with your explanation,
that's how you get over it.
And communication is crazy important.
If you don't communicate,
then people won't know
how good you are.
And vice versa.
And I feel a lot
when I overcommunicate,
When I'm like write, write, write
and then I say,
"Hey, wait, that's wrong."
And then go back to my software
and fix it.
A lot of times
when I explain something to somebody,
I figure out things myself.
So, talk, talk, talk.
Write, write, write
as much as possible.
Gil, I think that's such a great insight.
Because I think at the end,
what you're saying about context
is crucial.
We sometimes think for hours
about a problem
and we come up
with our resolution, right?
And it could be
three bullet resolution
of what we think should happen.
And we only provide the outcome,
but we sometimes neglect to provide
the whole thinking process,
which explains the rationale
behind the solution.
And even if the other person
understands it,
they might not accept it
or they might not even understand
our solution without the context
of the thinking process.
So, that's definitely
one of the most important lessons
that I'm taking with me from this.
Gil, I want to thank you
for both inspiration these 20 minutes.
But overall, I think
it's been maybe seven years
since we've been in contact.
So, thank you for that.
And thank you for helping
so many youth around Israel
and the world through hackathon,
through your journey.
And obviously, countless people
that are watching your lectures
and your presentations
on YouTube and live.
But before we leave,
I have to ask you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Fast.
Communicative.
And it didn't really come out this time,
but funny.
Lots of memes.
I can definitely testify for that.
Gil, thank you very much.
Stay safe and stay healthy.
Thank you.